chaque année ils sont des milliers de
professionnels à se rendre porte de
versailles à paris au salon iftm top
resa le salon international de
l'industrie du tourisme plus de 30000
visiteurs 160 destinations de rêve
parmi elles l île de la réunion avec son
stand de présentation riche en couleurs
est une destination qui retrouve ses
lettres de noblesse dit l'intense
intense intense mais intense en nature
intense en pour les intensément
réunionnaise intensément verte
intensément bleus avec l'océan et
intensément volcanique et c'est en tout
cas au goût du jour avec le volcan est
en éruption mais et c'est pour l'irt est
important d'être à paris d'être ici à
top resa pour représenter notre île sous
toutes ses facettes mille facettes mille
visages mille paysages que nous
présentons et c'est vraiment le touriste
experts expérientiel que nous allons
chercher du tourisme vient vivre une
expérience unique à la réunion en
contact avec les réunionnaises et les
réunionnais où il va on va essayer de le
prendre par la main l'accompagner tout
au long de son voyage
et pourquoi pas le faire réparer
lui-même un cari c'est ça l'expérience
pourquoi pas la mener vers une
distillerie géraniums et qui distille
lui-même quelques brins de géranium et
c'est super ce tourisme la expérientiel
où les gens fatigués
vie stressant dr la réunion pour vivre
ces expériences et pour se détendre
ce salon est le plus important rendez
vous des professionnels du voyage en
france
l'île de la réunion tourisme rassemble
autour de ce stand de nombreux
partenaires comme des hôteliers des
restaurateurs des agences de voyages et
également la compagnie aérienne locale
air austral la véritable espace
d'opportunités donc porno et de
rencontres est je dirais l'ensemble de
nos partenaires fournisseurs clients et
avec qui on peut véritablement faire le
point donc don de la situation et
éventuellement parler aussi du futur
je pense que c'est une occasion
absolument en or pur pour nous mêmes et
pour l'ensemble des participants et
promouvoir la réunion s'est également
promouvoir sa culture et sa diversité
la cuisine créole fait partie de cette
découverte intense de la réunion à cette
occasion le chef étoilé yves camdeborde
accompagné des lauréats du concours
master marmite ont revisité le
traditionnel cari de poulet
j'ai fait l'interprétation voilà deux du
cari poulet
j'ai essayé de ne pas les décevoir déjà
pour commencer et surtout j'ai essayé
voilà de conserver le goût initiale du
cari en le faisant un peu d'une façon je
verrai plus gastronomique par rapport à
la présentation des produits pays binger
nice et des produits voilà qu
entrepreneur régulièrement aussi sur le
continent c'est l'étranger le promu caen
par du gingembre quand on parle de
de l'ail de l'oignon de la citronnelle
de la tomate du curcuma c'est les
produits qui font partie de la culture
française c'est pas la réunion c'est la
france est donc déjà en france au
quotidien on les utilise alors peut-être
que les connaissent pas toujours de la
même façon il y en a de façon spécifique
parce qu'il ya un goût spécifique et une
façon de travailler des produits qui est
qui et en propre à la aux cuisiniers de
la réunion la présidente du département
étaient présentes à cette 38e édition du
salon et ftm top resa elle a salué tous
les acteurs économiques et touristiques
présents pour promouvoir la destination
réunion nassimah dindar a rappelé
l'engagement nécessaire des politiques
pour porter les projets structurants du
secteur touristique à la ring si les
politiques ne se mêle pas de tourisme je
crois qu'on pourra avoir le plus beau
matériaux qui existe et ce matériau sais
j'ai envie de dire
l'intelligence humaine réunionnaise on
peut avoir le plus beau territoire et ce
plus beau territoire c'est le classement
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco la 5e
nico région de lille c'est à dire les
peaux nous aurons tout ça mais nous
n'aurons pas les leviers qu'il faut sur
l'aérien sur les hôtels à construire sur
peut-être également la vision globale da
tourisme haut de gamme qui puisse aussi
s'allier à du tourisme affinitaire et
nous avons de très très bons